you
food and water of all the resources on
earth these two are the most vital for
survival abundance of food and water
allows civilizations to grow and thrive
while a scarcity relegate people to
spending their waking hours simply
trying to get enough to survive
according to the US Census Bureau the
current world population is estimated to
be around seven billion four hundred
million at the time of making this video
the question we're going to consider is
whether or not we're running out of food
to feed the growing world population the
majority of population suffering from
world hunger are those that live in
developing countries as of 2015 there
were approximately 156 million children
in the world that suffer from stunted
growth due to malnutrition and that's
just one of the potential complications
that can arise in areas without
sufficient access to food the root cause
of all such conditions is hunger we
often hear the term world hunger in the
media and we understand the general idea
but what does it really mean how do we
define the term hunger as it applies to
entire populations we typically define
hunger as a strong desire or need for
food or the painful or uncomfortable
sensations caused by its absence world
hunger is slightly different defined as
the want or scarcity of food in the
aggregate of world populations
unsurprisingly the main cause of world
hunger is poverty many people around the
world simply don't have sufficient
income to buy nutritious food directly
or to purchase land on which to grow
their own food this poverty has many
causes we'll take a brief look at four
of them first conflict in many African
and Middle Eastern countries war and
violence prevent people from having a
settled lifestyle often forcing them to
move around to avoid danger in Pakistan
alone in 2012 over 25 million people
were considered conflict affected
persons the next cause of poverty is the
rapidly expanding world population this
is the one that causes the most alarm
for much of the civilized world in no
small part thanks to the media the
concern is that soon there will simply
be too many mouths to feed and not
enough food to go around while largely
blown out of proportion the growing
world population does indeed make it
harder to feed everyone
number three is food and agricultural
policies some countries simply lack the
infrastructure or resources to run large
farms on which to grow food for their
citizens other countries simply have no
desire to eliminate hunger among their
people one resource called the hansi
index
measures African nations commitment to
ending hunger take Sudan for example
which is number 45 out of 45 making it
the very worst in terms of commitment
Sudan only spends 2.2 percent of its
total public spending on agriculture
finally the fourth main cause of world
hunger is climate change according to
world hunger org climate change is
increasingly viewed as a current and
future cause of hunger and poverty
increasing drought flooding and changing
climatic patterns requiring a shift in
crops and farming practices that may not
be easily accomplished our three key
issues of course this doesn't answer the
question are we running out of food
despite what you might expect no we're
not another statistic from world hunger
org states that for the world as a whole
per capita food availability has risen
from about 2,200 calories per person per
day in the early 1960s to two thousand
seven hundred ninety calories per person
per day in 2006 to 2008 while developing
countries even recorded a leak from 1850
calories per person per day to over two
thousand six hundred and forty this
means that yes the world does in fact
produce enough food to feed everyone
it's just a matter of providing that
food to affected areas in fact the
number of undernourished people in the
world has gone down in developing
countries from 34% in the mid 1970s to
just 15% three decades later child
malnutrition has also decreased
significantly since 1990 according to
World Bank the stunting prevalence of
children under five has gone down from
thirty nine point six percent in 1992
23.2 percent in 2015 and that number has
been steadily decreasing every year of
course while this is undoubtedly good
news there are still a huge number of
people suffering from hunger and
malnutrition around the world what are
we doing as a global society to fix
these problems
in 2015 the 193 member states of the
United Nations agreed on the significant
goal of totally ending poverty and world
hunger by 2030 their main means of
achieving this monumental goal include
doubling the agricultural production of
small farmers increasing access to food
in war-torn areas and brokering for
peace investing in agriculture and
infrastructure and adapting to climate
change starting with the first point the
plan to double agricultural production
might not be what you think according to
the Food and Agriculture Organization if
women farmers had the same access to
farming resources as men the number of
hungry people in the world would be
reduced by 150
million the UN plans to provide all
small-scale food producers especially
women in small family farms equal access
to land tools seeds pesticides credit
and markets to sell their produce this
plan alone is suspected to increase crop
yields by 200 percent next increasing
access to food in places like Syria and
many African countries volunteer and
humanitarian groups are finding it
increasingly difficult to connect with
the affected populations destroyed roads
non functioning refrigeration and
violent disruption are significant
roadblocks to feeding the hungry one
current temporary solution is to have
aid workers deliver vouchers instead of
actual food which can be taken to local
markets in exchange for various goods
this makes deliveries easier and safer
having to deliver food only to central
hubs rather than many individual
villages and camps it also provides some
amount of safety from robbery as the
vouchers have no monetary value of
course the only long-term solution will
be defined a way to resolve the many
conflicts causing the disruption
investing in agriculture and
infrastructure is a hugely promising
endeavor research by the FAO has shown
that investing in agriculture is up to
five times more effective at reducing
hunger and poverty than investing in any
other sector in mid-2015 the FAO the
World Food Programme and the
International Fund for agricultural
development presented a report that
suggested that a 105 billion dollar
investment in irrigation and food
processing infrastructure could very
possibly close the hunger gap one is ad
member said during the presentation we
won't see gains in reducing poverty and
hunger unless we seriously invest in
rural people given the right kinds of
tools and resources small-scale
agricultural producers and rural
entrepreneurs can transform struggling
communities into thriving places and
finally adapting to climate change the
numbers are alarming if we don't adapt
to the change in climate erosion
solidification and desertification will
raise childhood hunger and malnutrition
by up to 20 percent by 2050 the irony of
the situation is that livestock use for
food especially cows are one of the
biggest if not the biggest contributing
factor to manmade climate change a shift
away from large-scale livestock
cultivation could mitigate the effects
of climate change significantly over the
course of several years or decades the
UN's main plan for adaptation is to
preserve the biological diversity of
crops and livestock and ensure the use
of sustainable farming practices
according to the FAO up to 75% of crop
genetic diversity is already destroyed
22% of animal breeds are at risk and
more than half of fish stocks are fully
exploited adapting to climate change is
one of the most critical steps we can
take to ending world hunger that's all
well and good at the governmental level
but there are other options for us as
individuals if you'd like to help end
world hunger consider donating to one of
the charities listed in the description
for the cynics among us no I don't make
any money off those links they're simply
there because I'm certain there are
people watching this video who want to
make a difference if you enjoyed this
video don't forget to subscribe to keep
up to date with the latest content you
can watch my previous video by clicking
here or watch them all by clicking here
thanks for watching and I'll see you in
the next video
[Music]